[Music]
there's outrage and anger at the rape
and murder of the two teenage girls in
Uttar Pradesh demonstrators and rights
activists at this protest in Delhi
accused authorities in the state of not
being serious about tackling sexual
violence against women villagers found
the dead girls hanging from a tree
they then kept silent Watch refusing to
let authorities remove the bodies until
the suspects had been detained
doctors say post mortem show that both
girls suffered sexual attacks three men
stand accused of rape and murder two of
them have been arrested we sent a patrol
to arrests the third accused man the
search operation was carried out last
night and we also checked potential
hideouts but we couldn't find him on
email the father of one victim said the
girl's lives could have been saved if
police had acted earlier the case shines
a light on India's outlawed caste system
the girls are from the Dalit or
so-called Untouchables who often still
face widespread discrimination last year
India tightened its rape laws after the
gang rape and murder of a student
triggered international outrage this
latest case is one of the first
challenges for the new government of
Prime Minister Narendra Modi his
interior minister has already called for
an investigation